let's do a small thought experiment for
a second shall we
imagine that you are the president of
the united states of america
what kind of president would you
envision yourself to be
i guess that you would try to be
responsible charismatic
caring empathetic humble
resilient bold fair
enthusiastic supportive that would be
the answer of
most reasonable people on the planet
because
assuming the role of the president of
the most powerful country in the world
apart from a great privilege is also a
huge responsibility
not only because of the demands entailed
in every aspect of the role
but also because of the influence that
all has throughout every part of our
social strata
we choose our leaders not just to lead
us but also to represent us
our leaders shouldn't just be good at
giving orders and planning strategies
they should also embody the
characteristics of a person that would
act
as a healthy behavioral archetype for
the whole of society
yet our options in 2020 seem so far from
this reasoning
in this year's elections we need to face
a sad dilemma
on the one side we have trump the liar
authoritarian populist who took office
in 2016
in order to satisfy his personal
ambitions he took advantage of a
critical set of circumstances where
his opponents in the primaries weren't
something special
and a lot of people really disliked
hillary and didn't want to see her
becoming president
he used a very simple yet emotional
rhetoric and that
resonated with a surprisingly big number
of american voters
trump used the hitler textbook
diligently
he played with people's fears he used
the slogan make america great again
and he targeted immigrants in other
countries framing them as the main
source of the problems
the average american is facing i don't
know if trump is devious and he's just
acting in order to win votes or he
really believes the things he says
in any case he's dangerous on the other
side we have joe biden
a professional american politician with
more than 47 years of experience in the
american political landscape
i don't have much to say about biden
he's definitely not presidential
material
he has a questionable political
background he sometimes can't be
coherent with his thoughts
he lacks stamina he tries to be very
politically correct
and he's definitely pro-establishment as
you can see the dilemma is quite sad
and this clearly illuminates the rotten
nature of the american political system
this is 2020 instead of trying to tackle
the big questions surrounding human
existence and finding a way to optimize
life to a point where
complexity doesn't overwhelm us as much
as it does
we have to endure a political system
fueled by propaganda machines
that keeps dividing us polarizing us and
making our lives miserable
it's 2020 and instead of having a
president that resembles a father or
mother figure that is caring
assumes responsibility is humble tries
to unite us
and proposes fruitful dialogue that can
allow us to bridge our differences
we have this but
frank frank let me get to it and then i
watch this idiot lindsey graham on
television today
and he calls me a jackass he's a jackass
you brag that you have sexually
assaulted women
do you understand that no i didn't say
that at all i don't think you understood
what was said this was locker room talk
i believe in punishment for abortion yes
or no as a principle
the answer is that there has to be some
form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form such a nasty word
this is the legacy of hillary clinton
death destruction terrorism
and weakness is there anybody you'd like
to apologize to right now yourself
uh no no president obama
he is the founder of isis he's the
founder of isis
okay he's the founder
oh throw him the hell out of here
am i allowed to rip that whistle out of
the mouth i'd rip that
go home to mommy i love the old days you
know what they used to do to guys like
that when they were in a place like this
they'd be carried out on a stretcher
folks
and we end up like this
bye
but i guess it all comes down to our
very nature
we're still primates in nape societies
for instance
the loudest male of the group gets the
most respect
these are pant hoots they're a call
sign distinctive to each individual
chimp
and in alpha males it's all about making
as much noise as possible i don't want
to draw a parallel here but
you get the idea at the end of the day i
guess it's not a fight between
us and the status quo or us and the
political system
it is a fight between us and our own
nature
a fight with our biases a fight with our
instincts
a fight with our fears
personally i'm a left-leaning person
that is
i support progressive and humane
policies and i want to see my
representatives
fight against inequality against
corruption
and against anything that tries to
cancel our freedoms but at the same time
i understand history
i understand the complexity of our
social systems and i understand how
different conflicts of interest are
shaping the fabric of our institutions
that burdens me with the responsibility
of trying to deeply fathom the mechanics
of the world i inhabit
as a rational thinking human being that
wants to see this world progressing
towards
betterment balance equality and the
erasure of human suffering i do my
research and my due diligence
i said before that being the president
is both a privilege
and a responsibility the same accounts
for voters in a democratic society
the fact that you have the right to vote
constitutes a privilege and a
responsibility
you can't view politics like sports you
can't say i like this party better
because i like its scholars or its logo
or its abstract views on different
policies or
how its leader speaks all these are just
branding
and branding is the facade of the party
not its substance
in the great philosophical work the
republic plato describes how socrates
believes that
democracies he roughly said that the
average person is not capable of
evaluating the skills of a politician
therefore only intellectual people who
think about issues rationally and deeply
should be allowed to exercise the
privilege of voting
he might be right to some degree but i'm
not going to agree with him because
democracy is the basis of individual
freedom and expression of will
but when we laugh at this written by a
nice reporter now the poor guy you got
to see this guy oh i don't know what i
said ah
i don't remember he's gonna like i don't
remember i had
oh maybe that's what i said this is 14
years ago he still
they didn't do a retraction that
reporter he is talking about is serge
kovaleski who now works for the new york
times
as you can see right there he suffers
from a chronic condition that impairs
movement of his arms a time spokesman
says they find it outrageous that trump
would ridicule the man's appearance
when we laugh at this we're clearly not
mature politically and we're not worthy
of our democracy
we don't want a comedian in office we
want a serious person who is ready to
face
alongside us every challenging event
that comes our way
but usually we get what we deserve and
in order to deserve better
we need to start thinking better
the fact that trump was elected
president might be alarming but
it also showcases something remarkable
the current political system might be
powerful but
it's not unbeatable trump understood the
mechanics of influence and politics and
by
capitalizing on years of honing his
persuasion skills
he outperformed his opponents i can lie
to you
he won fair and square and his
achievement was quite impressive
so the fact that a lot of intellectuals
or thinkers come out and criticize him
is kind of hypocritical i mean
regardless of his views and tactics
at least he fought really hard for his
cause and he made it
he won not only because some people
resonated with his views
but also because a lot of people wanted
to see a person in office
that had nothing to do with the
political establishment it was a
fu vote a few votes to the whole
political system
and its representatives so all those
progressive liberal and even
conservative thinkers that as acting
behavioral archetypes
could do a better job than trump let
that happen with their apathy
and inaction i'm not saying that it is
easy to fight the political
establishment
it is well organized and well funded but
it's not unbeatable
people are not stupid they want chains
and i'm sure that
they're ready to fight for change they
just don't know how
great intellectuals and thinkers have
their chance to make history now
they have the chance to contribute even
more i think it's time for them to
escape the confines of their comfort
zones with their
cute little podcasts and books and
universities
i think it's time for them to actively
partake in the political landscape
i think it's time to fight back all of
us need to fight back
change won't happen overnight we're
talking about monumental structural
changes here
that require the active participation of
all of us and we need to start with the
basics
for instance a lot of us still do not
vote especially young people
in the ages 18 to 29 only 45 percent of
the people vote
when more people vote we put even more
pressure to our representatives
and that clearly affects their behavior
and decision making
famous youtuber johnny harris explains
that perfectly democracy is
a game of pressuring and signaling
leaders
let me explain what i mean leaders of
course take note of
protests and petitions and other forms
of activism
but the thing they really care about the
thing that really pressures them
is the vote because that is the only
thing that can actually lose them their
jobs
even if your candidate loses let's say
you are
a red person voting in a blue state or a
blue person voting in a red state or
whatever the winner of that election
will still note the results of their
opponent
if there's a huge turnout for your
candidate even though they lost
the winner of that election will notice
and they will take note
and they will factor that into their
behavior into their decision making
that is a fact that is how democracy
works because they need to keep an eye
on it because they realize that if there
was a big turnout for their opponent
this time they need to keep an eye on
that
for the next election on the other hand
if you don't vote and you stay home that
candidate who won has
zero pressure they feel zero pressure to
behave any differently because they won
so comfortably voting isn't just about
voting for the winner
it's about signaling to everyone what
the actual political diversity is
in your city or your county or your
state or your country
when you don't vote candidates don't
feel any pressure
and this helps them behave any way they
want also a third-party vote is quite
important because
it converses the foundation of this
two-party system
in my opinion not having many parties in
the parliament
is analogous to succumbing to oligarchy
as you can see the road ahead is no bed
of roses whenever i feel overwhelmed by
the whole situation
i like to read history history is full
of lessons
lessons about the progress we have made
but also lessons about similar
happenstances in history
that can help us learn from our mistakes
we did great so far
we crashed dictatorships we invested in
human rights
we cured diseases and technology has
improved our living conditions
yet as it looks like we still have a lot
of work to do
we're waking up to a new reality where
the current system no longer serves us
and we need
change every change has its winners and
its losers
and there are a lot of people who
benefit from the current status quo
the fight is inevitable that's why we
need to be prepared for anything
that's why we need to be prepared to
fight for the right
side of history
i've been drinking no driving while
texting the speed and i swear that i
ain't going home